my story is about the first female
elected to federal office in Iowa she's
also the first female combat veteran to
become a u.s. senator her name is Joni
or she's got a lot of first in her life
she now appears to be in a close race
for her second term the Iowa Republican
has just released her new book it's
called daughter of the heartland my ode
to the country that raised me Joni Ernst
will tell you she's a very proud
farmer's daughter it's published by
Thresh threshold editions that's an
imprint of Simon & Schuster which by the
way is a division of Viacom CBS before
joining the Senate or it's served in the
Iowa National Guard she got her first
there she was a first battalion
commander and the US Army Reserve she
was deployed to Kuwait and Iraq so she
says she knows what boots on the ground
really means senator Ernst joins us
first on CBS this morning from Urbandale
Iowa senator erst it's really good to
see you this morning
I'm gonna begin with a question heads up
it's got a lot of numbers in it Iowa was
one of seven states not to have a
stay-at-home order
you've got close to 18,000 Kovach cases
so far nearly 500 deaths and the cases
are still continuing I think since
Sunday there have been another 350 cases
do you think that the governor should
have issued a stay-at-home order in your
state I think our governor has taken all
the necessary steps and has followed the
CDC recommendations for our beautiful
state we do have metro areas and certain
hotspots and in those communities
certainly the local elected officials
are working diligently with the governor
and then there are other locations like
where I'm from which is very rural
farmland where we are trying to get our
economy up and going so I do think the
governor has taken all the necessary
precautions and she is working very
closely with our local elected officials
Mitch McConnell said that there is a
high likelihood of another coronavirus
relief package what is a good deal look
like to you you know you've got some
meatpacking plants in Iowa that are
concerned so what's a good deal for you
at this stage well yes working together
of course we need to make sure that
there are
ability protections in place for those
businesses that are getting things back
up and going in our economy focusing on
individuals to those essential workers
that have been on the front lines and
really carrying the brunt and the weight
of the pandemic focusing on them those
healthcare workers are truck drivers or
grocers those folks working in the meat
packing facilities and food industries
they're all heroes for keeping our
families safe and healthy and we want to
make sure we're focusing on them as well
we all agree with that
you know the Trump administration has
said testing let's let's talk about
testing for just a sec because I really
do want to get to your book the Trump
administration says testing should be
left to the states
medical experts appear to say we need
uniform testing around the country what
do you think I think it's a combination
of both certainly and we need those
guidances coming from the federal
government and then programs that can be
pushed out by the states and the local
authorities working conjunction
hand-in-hand federal government and
local public health agencies I think
would be a great way to get as many
tests out to our population as possible
and I think once we start seeing that
everybody will feel a lot better about
going out in their communities if they
know where those hotspots are where to
avoid and maybe some areas where we can
open up all right senator Ernst learned
a lot about you reading your books for
instance at the age of seven your dream
was to be a nurse a farmer's wife or
Miss America that dream didn't go so
well for you senator earth what happened
well I didn't realize those goals but I
did go from that little girl on a family
farm certainly to some greater
aspirations I never imagined that I
would be serving in the United States
especially through a number of
challenges that I've been through in my
lifetime but I am so grateful and the
title of my book says it all it's the my
ode to the country that really means we
are
so blessed to be in such a tremendous
nation where you can be a farm girl
growing up in rural Iowa and then serve
your nation in uniform as well as serve
your constituents and in the Senate
senator senator not just a farm girl but
a farm girl that is castrated hogs when
she was young who wore plastic bag on
her shoes
to save her shoes you talk about growing
up as a farmer's daughter you said it
was excellent training you said for
challenges you faced in military and now
in public office your tagline now reads
mother soldier senator go you so how was
how was the way you raised affected
affected you and and and really gave
good examples for you when you had
military life in public office because
you do draw a correlation between the
two yes and thank you Gail because I
grew up with a mom and dad that really
believed you had to pitch in and work
and a lot of that was manual labor
that's what farming entails so not being
afraid to get my hands dirty
understanding there is no job beneath me
and that really instilled the values and
the work ethic that have carried me on
through the military challenging myself
in various situations and knowing that I
can overcome and of course always
circling back to gratitude knowing that
I couldn't have done all of this without
wonderful friends and family supporting
me yeah you know and Senator listen
you've had a lot to overcome you write
very candidly I have to say very
pointedly about abuse you suffered from
a boyfriend at a very early age then
later in your marriage abuse and
infidelity and you said all of those
certainly changed you but what is your
message to women who have gone through
it or who are going through it now you
have a very clear point of view on this
yeah my story is a very raw story but
it's not a story that is unusual across
the United States and I've had many
women that have thanked me for being so
candid about whether it's sexual or
physical abuse and my my
point to other women and other young
ladies out there is that this is what a
mom can be this is what a mom can do she
can work she can serve in the military
she can serve in elected office she can
raise a family there are so many things
and opportunities we just have to know
how to pick ourselves up after having
those challenging situations drive
through it all and know that we can be
all of these things we can be
aspirational and generational yes and
you said you know you you you think
about your daughter
20 year old Libby I'm so glad that you
have her in your life as someone who you
said suffered from low self-esteem and
low self-worth you certainly turned that
around senator erst we thank you thank
you and good luck with your book it's
called daughter of the Hartland
it's on sale now wherever you like to
buy your book